it's been a decade of signs and wonders
ten years it's pretty extraordinary it
is just the most remarkable achievement
what's going on everybody Marvel is
still celebrating 10 years Congrats
Marvel this 10 years has been amazing I
think I speak for mostly everybody that
we have all thoroughly enjoyed it as
much as you all have enjoyed making the
movies the beginning of the clip that
you guys just saw was something that
Marvel put out today celebrating their
10 year anniversary and I loved watching
it took me back through all of the 10
years through a lot of the movies kind
of lets you reminisce and it gave me the
tingles okay I'm getting pinkles I
wanted you all to see it as well so here
you go congratulations and thank you to
Marvel Studios for an amazing 10 years
it's a very conscious act to go and make
a motion picture let alone think about
launching and sustaining a cinematic
universe I mean nobody had even heard of
that five or six years ago
I'm Peter Connelly Doctor Strange all
use made-up names pretty old since to
say this yeah collective isn't it I mean
just fit parts of it it's crazy
fit any more people on that poster and
everyone deserves to be there you know
everyone has fought for their place in
the MCU it's such an amazingly humble
group of people and everyone's easy to
work with there are team players
surprise this will be such fun I love
all these actors they made it so fun
it's it's like a big family
and everything was a bit off nothing
much really we're all having fun and
were really allowed to be the best
versions of whatever these giant movies
are
you're given a set of circumstances and
a script and you go try to put your
secret sauce on that and make it fun and
entertaining and I think what's
extraordinary is how that baton has been
passed in such a magnanimous way from
all these franchises hi I'm Steve Rogers
now bring them all together it's just so
epic are you yawning to have created
these different worlds and made them so
sort of full and rich and then bring
them all together for these last two
movies it's so great it's really been
ten years in the making and is a very
very unique film I'm glad it's worked
out this way because we had been working
our asses off for a while
to have come this far 19 movies 10 years
and still be going and still have people
wanting it and still be doing something
that's new and profound and culturally
significant that's a dream come true
[Music]
one of the things that I love the most
about this is seeing all the actors talk
so highly of each other and seeing the
dynamic behind the scenes it truly is an
amazing cast the actors are all amazing
and as I mentioned in the video every
single one of them has fought so hard to
be in the MCU I love this video
I thought it was a great thing for
Marvel to put out I loved seeing all the
actors joke around with each other
behind the scenes and if you're not a
way of starting August 30th theatres
around will be showing every single one
of the Marvel videos in theaters on IMAX
that's 20 videos being shown for a week
starting August 30th and also don't
forget about the giveaway that I am
doing I'm giving away a few copies of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray all you
have to do to enter the giveaway is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero also be sure to give me your
thoughts on this Marvel 10 year
anniversary video thank you all so much
for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you